welcome back to this special edition of
Hannity Democrats are now openly telling
each other not to completely freak out
about the possibility of Joe Biden
losing big next year but the Dems have
good reason to be really worried right
now Donald Trump leads Biden by a
significant margin in almost every swing
state not to mention overall Nationwide
and in this time of personal and
political crisis for the president
what's Joe doing well he's hiding out at
the thir $4 million mansion of a friend
on N Tucket taking a Polar Plunge in the
frigid water with his family watching
his kids and grandkids take selfies and
photos on the dock and on the beach and
of course shopping with his son Hunter
Joe doesn't seem to have a care in the
world right now and he better enjoy
himself because next year it's not
shaping up to be a fun one for him here
with reaction is the author of the new
book The Constitution of the United
States and other patriotic documents Fox
News legal analyst Greg Jarrett along
with Democratic strategist Doug
Shon and Tammy Bruce Fox News
contributor is also joining us uh Doug
but I want to start with you because I
mean Joe Biden in swing States uh it
doesn't look too good at this point now
polls change Obama was behind and he
came back but I don't see how in the
world Joe Biden the policies aren't on
his side and doesn't he's not going to
have more Vigor it's not like more
cowbell with Joe Biden out on the
campaign Trail can solve these
problems well Jason you're right uh his
poll numbers are dropping his approval
rating is is at or below 40% which is
beyond a danger sign the only thing he
really has going for him is what's
worked before abortion and a negative
campaign against the likely Republican
nominee Donald Trump and that's why
Democrats are rallying around him it's
worked before they're hoping it can work
again yeah Tammy um you know hanging out
on a $34 million mansion on the beach
while you know Wars are raging and
Americans are are struggling um that's
not exactly the best look is it I mean
he just seems to be oblivious to that or
just that doesn't care or I mean I just
think that's who he is but it's really
not a good look is it yeah you know it's
it's how they've lived uh it is um an
outrageous display considering the
financial issues that he and his family
are facing that are uh you know
questionable to say the least that in
fact could you know dealing with money
and favors from other countries uh the
issue of of bribery being discussed so
it is a very interesting Dynamic when
Americans are still asking how is it
that you can spend your life in public
service and be living this kind of
luxurious lifestyle we're getting a hint
of perhaps how but I think what this
tells us Jason is that this is just
simply what it's been like for most of
his adult life it's what his family's
life has been like they've lived off the
largess of the American taxpayer it has
been a game to them they see what our
our hard work is being something that
gets them their beach houses and I want
everyone to be successful make no
mistake about that but this is in a in a
sort of a way kind of robbery when
you're doing things for your own benefit
when you're supposed to be doing things
for the country's benefit and you're
doing it because it's getting you you
know rich and it's not just him but
investing apparently his entire family
so in a in a holiday where money is a
problem where the economy is tough where
uh uh over 70% of Americans don't like
the direction of the country
they're almost thumbing their noses at
us and I think obviously that's going to
move through next year as
well now Greg I want you to listen to
Jen saki this is day one of the Biden
Administration where she was promise
promising us openness and transparency I
want to get your reaction on the other
side of this when the president asked me
to serve in this role we talked about
the importance of bringing truth and
transparency back to the briefing room
but his objective and his commit
is to bring transparency and Truth back
to government uh to share the truth even
when it's hard to
hear it it's been hard to hear because I
don't think I've heard much of it from
them yeah none of it is true and the
American public has reacted adversely
and now the campaign for Joe Biden is
begging Democrats to Rally behind him
and look pleading the case for Joe Biden
is like defending the indefensive it's
hypocritical and it's phony which is why
his support is sinking you know to most
Americans suffering under inflation and
high interest rates and a crushing
economy the slogan byonics is an ugly
epithet people can't afford Biden nomics
so when Joe Biden keeps touting it he's
only reinforcing his own negative and
then you factor in the Border disaster
the flood of migrants surging crime
foreign policy blunders an incompetent
running maid in kamla Harris and his own
mental infirmities and you've got an
electr that is soured decidedly on Joe
Biden and no amount of remsing Jason can
Rectify this perception of failure
that's reflected in the polls the remedy
is to reverse course but it's way too
late for that Joe Biden is wedded to
this leftist agenda that has proven more
destructive than and constructive and
voters Jason are
alienated Doug you mentioned earlier you
know there's the abortion issue right
they're obviously going to use that but
and they talk about biomics I don't know
that they've ever really truly defined
what bomx means because you could try to
tell people numbers are better and good
but if they don't feel it they don't
feel it so you're you're a very bright
strategist what do you think they're
going to do over the next 12 months to
actually make the difference that they
need well you know I I wish I could
disagree with you uh Jason certainly
with what Greg and Tammy have said but I
can't and I know both uh as a real world
uh uh person living dayto day that
inflation interest rates are tough on
people which is why I said before and I
would reiterate expect very little as
the camp campaign gets started about
failed
policies expect attacks on Donald Trump
uh fear-mongering on what will happen
when the Republicans take power on
abortion and other issues because when
you can't win with a positive campaign
you go negative and it worked in 2018
2020 and 22 and even in the 23 offe
elections that's what we're going to get
that's what they're going to do
that's what they're being told by their
strategists given what you're hearing
tonight which is all fair and accurate I
must
confess Tammy and Greg we have a very
short amount of time but a do you think
Joe Biden will continue to be the
nominee and do you think they just go n
nuclear and just say you know scorched
Earth everything's bad mag is bad
everything's bad is that their only way
out
yeah well you know he spent uh 50 his 50
years in government to get to this point
he's not going to give it up easily he
doesn't want to the people running him
want to remain in power anybody else who
actually wants to be a president will
not want the same team involved and
you're you're going to see more
buildings you know drenched in red light
they already have contempt for the
American people they they believe we're
idiots they think they can move through
on the same theme it's up to us to make
sure that they're wrong but I think as
long as he can hang on with his
fingernails he will be the nominee uh
and I I don't know if that's going to
change but it'll be a big fight in order
for it to to
change Greg to you we've only height
what's your thought at the height of
Vietnam uh it was abundantly clear to
LBJ that he was probably not going to
get reelected he did the right thing uh
held an address in front of the American
people and said he was not going to run
uh Joe Biden is no lynon Johnson
Joe Biden seems addicted to the perks of
office preoccupied with luxury and
wealth he's not about to give it up and
his enablers his families enjoy it just
as much as he does they will continue to
urge him to run for reelection even
though he'll be more than 86 years old
by the end of the next term if
reelected I happen to think the right
answer is I don't think Joe Biden will
be the nominee I think Thanksgiving or
around the Christmas holidays good time
to to bow out and even though the
Republicans may have the best candidate
in all the issues or at least the
majority of the issues on their side the
ground game of the Democrats still gives
them the advantage they have leveraged
that they have used that and Republicans
don't have much of an answer that's
that's my worry that's my concern that's
my perspective Greg Doug and Tammy Happy
Thanksgiving thanks for joining us
tonight on hanity hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else